the Democratic presidential hopefuls are
spending the weekend campaigning in Iowa
it began last night 410 of the
contenders at a forum on gay rights at
the event frontrunner Joe Biden raised
some eyebrows when he said he was an
early supporter of same-sex rights
political correspondent ed O'Keefe is in
Iowa and good morning good morning Dana
gay rights has been a big issue here in
the first in the nation caucus state for
several years it's just one of the
issues presidential candidates are
talking about in their mad dash for
voters back when some Democrats were
talking about civil unions I was
performing marriages in 2004 at San
Francisco City Hall
I remember serving under Don't Ask Don't
Tell and I also remember the weight
lifted when that was no longer a threat
to my career Democratic presidential
candidates Friday night took turns
explaining how they protect gay lesbian
and transgender rights Donald Trump has
the strategy he's got a plan his
strategy is turn people against people
despite having pushed then President
Obama to support same-sex marriage
former Vice President Joe Biden had to
strongly defend his gay rights record
amid questions of his past work with
Republicans you have also praised Vice
President Mike Pence as a decent guy a
lovely person I came out and meet the
press and support of gay marriage before
anybody else did Matthews I didn't have
to evolve the forum came as candidates
are once again focused on winning over
Iowa voters with the caucus here only
about a hundred thirty days away I'm not
gonna change who I am you're gonna get
exactly what I am one candidate doubling
down in Iowa is California senator
Kamala Harris who despite slipping back
in polls here now says she's determined
to finish in the top three it can be
frustrating frankly to have to make
these these
decisions that that feel like a
trade-off but I plan on spending as much
time as I can here in order to win
Harris has to convince voters like John
elphic he said his three favorite
candidates are Biden Harris and
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
it's a little harder this time because
there's so many so many candidates in
one night elphic attended a Harris rally
and an event held by Warren having seen
both of them now and one night you meet
a lot of undecided voters like John
these days here in Iowa and today
another big and tasty political event
that they can attend the steak fry being
held here in Des Moines where they grill
not fry at least 10,500 steaks for
12,000 attendees who will get a chance
to hear from 17 Democratic presidential
candidates if you're vegan if you're a
kid don't worry they have options for
you too it's a lot to chew on it and we
know how important Iowa is in the early
voting especially candidates trying to
make up some of that ground like Kamala
Harris but there are changes to how the
caucuses are going to be held next year
what are those and what's the impact
yeah remember when you go to a caucus
you have to show up at a specific time
and a specific place depending on your
precinct but just yesterday Iowa
Democrats got permission to hold what
are called satellite caucuses allowing
maybe shift workers at a factory or a
hospital to gather together that night
and make their decision the idea is to
boost participation among Democrats
across the state and there's a good
chance that could favor certain
candidates alright ed thank you